today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
i want to start today with something a
little different and and very
interesting and important in
understanding a lot of the the
structures that have gotten
the politics of the united states to
where they are today
uh we're going to look at a new poll
from the new york times
uh from new york times with siena
college
and it's not about who's winning biden
or trump
it's really about one of the fundamental
uh inequalities that we have in the
united states it's not income inequality
which we'll talk about later today with
our guest
it is a poll that confirms something
i've been talking about for many years
which is that on the
issues the united states electorate
meaning people
you me us we are well to the left
uh compared to number one what many
people might assume is the the
left-right balance of the country
but maybe more importantly the country
is to the left of where our elected
representatives are our elected
representatives are far more
conservative than the makeup of the
united states
we have a country where if you go to
individual people and you ask them about
policy very important you ask about
policy issues policy questions
you come away with the impression that
the country is quite quite left
certainly more left than many people are
willing to admit
but then you look at governors and you
look at state legislatures and you look
at the makeup of the senate and the
makeup of corporate media
and it sort of seems like a center-right
country but as i've told you before
we have three to four different systems
in this country
that keep our representation well to the
right of the actual electorate so
let's not get ahead of ourselves let's
go through it in pieces
this is one of those types of stories
which you know it doesn't
it's not a click bait story it's not
going to get 500
000 views on youtube but if you don't
understand this you miss a lot of
why the country is the way it is so it's
really important to do
first and foremost the new york times
poll asked likely voters about their
positions
on a variety of issues and when you look
at the numbers there's nothing
center-right about this country for
example
72 percent of the country wants a second
two trillion dollar corona coronavirus
stimulus package
72 percent only 21 oppose
a second coronavirus stimulus in a
country this
polarized and seemingly divided 72
percent agreement on anything is
stunning
72 percent want the 2 trillion second
stimulus
how about this 67 of the country
believes there should be a public health
insurance option
now i know it's not single-payer it's
not medicare for all but remember
when the debate started in 2010 2009
about the affordable care act
obamacare president obama started the
negotiation at you know i'd like a
public option
the republican party went crazy
pretending it was some kind of
socialist government takeover of health
care and yet
67 percent of this country agrees we
should we should have it when you hear
trump talk about we're going to get rid
of obamacare at rallies and his crowd
cheers and fox news
talks about it in less than glowing
terms you might get the impression that
there's a lot of debate among the public
but
67 percent of the country agrees this is
some
something we should have something uh uh
seem something this controversial
with hundreds of millions of dollars
spent in opposition
and two-thirds of the country flat out
says we should have
uh we should have this option there
should be such a government option
now it gets more interesting joe biden's
two trillion dollar
climate plan which donald trump and
republicans present
pretend is crazy they say it'll end the
auto industry
they say it'll end fossil fuel industry
they say it's outrageous
it's socialist 66 of the country
supports joe biden's two trillion dollar
climate plan
which includes getting back into the
paris climate accords
some elements using the green new deal
as a framework
phasing out fossil fuel vehicles on and
on and on two-thirds of the country
wants it
even things that have become almost
rallying cries
of the right like their opposition to a
national mass mandate which by the way
would really be a president saying hey
governors please
do mask mandates in your states and it
would ultimately be up to governors
whether to do it or not
59 of the country wants a national mass
mandate
here's another interesting one fracking
donald trump and republicans have made a
huge deal out of saying joe biden will
ban fracking
it's not actually what biden would do
biden has a plan
to phase it out over time but as if
continuing to frack is so important
trump has been hammering hammering
hammering biden on that
only 44 of the country wants fracking to
exist
an almost equal amount 42 percent
doesn't and 14 percent
isn't sure a big portion of that i
believe if they learn more about it
would would be would be against fracking
so this is not a right wing country
when you look at this i mean even if you
just say let's only look at policies
with 60
approval or higher 60 or higher support
that would mean we get a two trillion
dollar second coronavirus stimulus
public health insurance and biden's two
trillion dollar
climate plan that's just if we set the
line at
sixty percent and we say only do things
where 60 percent of the country
agrees that's three major policies
that would be a major leftward switch so
we then must ask the question
why does the senate have 53 republicans
why do we have 26 republican governors
why is it so hard to remove a lunatic
republican president
and as i've said before we have systems
that favor
the american right example number one
electoral college the electoral college
system
has handed republican wins to republican
candidates
who lost the popular vote much like on
the issues
the will of the people was to elect the
democrat
the electoral college handed it to a
republican that's a systemic
help to the right example number two
gerrymandering which is the strategic
drawing of congressional districts
has allowed way more republican members
of the house than you would have
with fairly drawn districts the
democratic party would have a bigger
majority right now were not for
gerrymandering
there are previous republican majorities
which may have not been republican
majorities
were it not for gerrymandering systemic
help
to the american right example number
three
the senate as an institution when you
give each state to senators
and the states vary widely in population
low population states get
disproportionately more power california
has
60 70 times the population of wyoming
california has two senators wyoming has
two senators
wyoming is a red state wyoming senators
have insanely more power
relative to their populations than
california
because conservatives prefer on average
to live
more rurally whereas democrats
left-wingers progressives
prefer to live more uh in in urban or
suburban settings
at a systemic level that gives more
power to fewer right leaning people so
the key takeaways here are not to get
tricked by really bad talking points for
many on the right including talking
points like
this is a center-right country it's not
when you fairly pull
people on issues you see that this is a
center-left to left
country and number two we have systemic
elements of how our system is organized
that have our representation be far to
the right
of what the actual country believes on a
number of different issues
something to keep in mind as we go
forward over the next two weeks towards
this upcoming election
speaking of going forward to the
election we actually have
some what i think is overall very good
news and
news that is extremely triggering for
the president of the united states
donald trump the second and final
presidential debate is this thursday
and candidate microphones will be muted
during the initial answer periods when
the other candidate is speaking this is
not going to apply
during the open discussion period you're
still going to have back and forth
during the open discussion but as you
might remember
during the first presidential debate
donald trump just would not stop talking
interrupting joe biden it wasn't clear
whether trump was
sort of manically outbursting or whether
it was a strategy to try to throw biden
off or a combination of the two
but it made the debate worthless in
terms of hearing policy ideas although
it does seem to have hurt donald trump
in polling because of his childish
petulant behavior so
when the uh we then after that first
debate
had the commission on presidential
debates announce
that what should have been the second
debate would happen via video conference
because
trump had coronavirus and trump said not
going to do it remote
they can silence you whenever they want
if you do that and he backed out of the
debate altogether
so we now have one debate to go the last
debate scheduled for thursday night and
indeed during the initial two-minute
answer periods
the microphone of the candidate not
speaking will be
muted the commission on presidential
debates
said in a statement that quote we
realize after discussions with both
campaigns
that neither campaign may be totally
satisfied with the measures announced
today
one may think they go too far and one
may think they do not go far enough
we are comfortable that these actions
strike the right strike the right
balance
and that they are in the interest of the
american people
for whom these debates are held now
there were some people
who soon after the first debate and
people started calling for the muting of
microphones said
if you mute the mics it's not really a
debate if you mute mics it's sequential
talking points it eliminates debate it
eliminates the possibility
of a back and forth this is a balanced
approach
in the sense that of each 15-minute
block
four minutes will be reserved
exclusively for one candidate or the
other
after the four minute period two minutes
two minutes for each candidate
then the microphones are open it's open
discussion so i think it will undeniably
make the debate more watchable
there are people wondering whether it's
really even better for biden one would
imagine that letting biden kind of lay
out his ideas uninterrupted will help
him
and i think it would the counter is does
it help him more
than the damage trump does by just
talking over biden during those initial
couple of minutes
biden could have helped himself by
speaking uninterrupted but trump
really cratered in the polls after that
first debate
in the end again there will be time for
both
four of each 15 minutes will be uh
including mike muting so it's a
relatively small adjustment
uh bottom line these are the updated
rules and donald trump is already not
pleased
he said yesterday to reporters after
being told about this change
i'll participate i just think it's very
unfair
trump also spent time at a rally in
prescott arizona yesterday attacking the
moderator
of this week's debate who is kristen
welker take a listen to that
another real great one another great one
kristen welker she's a radical democrat
look at him they're getting angry
she's a radical democrat she deleted her
entire account everything is deleted
but i've known her she's been screaming
questions of me for
a long time and she's no good
so trump attacking the moderator there
and then reportedly the president is
also not happy that as he sees it the
topics were changed
trump kept saying the debate thursday
night was on foreign policy
and now for example coronavirus is a
topic
i always thought that foreign policy was
not the subject of thursday night's
debate but trump is angry claiming they
changed the topics
on him so bottom line um i think there's
a chance trump
does back out i would put it probably at
about 20
i hope he doesn't i hope this debate
does happen but it's very funny how for
months
donald trump had been saying oh biden's
going to find a way out biden's brain's
not working he can't handle debating me
and then it's trump who bailed on debate
number two
and it's trump who's not pleased with
the guidelines for debate number three
now a
serious question and a lot of people are
asking about this
is trump going to just try to interrupt
anyway even if he's off mike
my guess is if trump tried to do it yeah
it would look very bad
but you would be able to probably hear
donald trump's voice if he tries to
interrupt
interrupt joe biden picked up both by
joe biden's microphone maybe as much as
by the moderator's microphone so i think
it's something trump could do
um i think if he does it it would look
very very bad and reports are that
trump's advisors and
people prepping him for the debate have
been advising him not to interrupt
and to sort of try to be more likeable
uh even if trump likes the idea
of being more liked as i'm sure his ego
would would like donald trump has a very
hard time controlling himself and donald
trump has a very hard time
listening to people who give him advice
because he thinks he knows better than
everybody so my prediction is
that in nashville 9 p.m eastern on
thursday night which is when the debate
starts
my prediction is that trump's behavior
will be very similar to what we saw in
debate number one at the beginning he
might be more under control
i think he will eventually lose it i
hope you will watch the debate with me
i will be streaming live on youtube
twitch and facebook
starting maybe 30 45 minutes before the
debate
join me then and we will take it all
in together if you're not going to watch
the debate
i'm curious about why let me know on
twitter where you can find me
at d pacman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember to grab yourself a membership
on my website
joinpakman.com the primary funding
source of this program
is just people good people like you i'm
sure
uh who go to join pacman.com and sign up
for a membership hey this is very very
interesting
now that the entire hunter biden story
from the new york
post has been very much called into
question mediaite is reporting
that fox news was actually approached
with the story before the new york
poster at least concurrently and could
have made a decision to run it
as soon as or even earlier than the new
york post and of course
it was donald trump's henchman rudy
giuliani who approached them with the
hunter biden story
the story it turns out was too crazy and
too incredible and too poorly sourced
for fox news to go with it fox news
reportedly looked at the story
realized that they couldn't vet the
sourcing they couldn't vet the veracity
of the emails
and they passed on it and on it went to
the new york post and there's a few
different interesting layers here
to talk about now first of all um just
because fox news didn't publish it
doesn't mean they haven't promoted it
and in fact fox news has been going
crazy with the story but the idea was
fox news because the new york post was
the
original source on the story can talk
about it
not as their reporting but just as here
is what the new york post story says and
it kind of puts a
layer between them and the story while
still allowing them to talk about it so
understand how far this has gone
so far from the original story
originally the new york post reports it
trump is saying it's a bombshell but it
seems a little bit fishy
contains things that were previously
debunked like it again raises the idea
that joe biden
was involved in the firing of a
prosecutor in ukraine
because hunter biden asked him to do it
in his role as
a board member of the ukrainian energy
company burisma that was debunked
and a bunch of other elements were were
debunked and it sort of looked like wow
if these emails are real it seems like
joe biden loves his son that was one of
the big takeaways
we then learned that the reporter who
wrote the story primarily wrote the
story
didn't even want his name on it because
it was so shaky
and that other new york post staffers
says take my name off of the the story i
don't even want my byline on there
i don't even think we should be
publishing this story at all that's kind
of weird
then we hear that rudy giuliani says
well yeah it is a 50 50 shot
that he worked on the story with a
russian spy
and then now we learn that fox news of
all places decided it was below them
to publish the story and even some
people
on air at fox news channel have said the
story's a little weird
check out for example what chris wallace
said about it
and about rudy giuliani as well you know
i can understand the concern about this
story it is completely unverified and
frankly rudy giuliani is not the most
reliable source anymore i hate to say
that
but it's just true there's a story in
the washington post in the new york
times today
saying that the national security
adviser
robert o'brien had to tell the president
in december of last year that uh
the intelligence agencies thought that
giuliani was being worked by russian
agents and was being used to spread
russian disinformation
that is fox news anchor chris wallace
saying this but again just as a reminder
fox news isn't off the hook here
fox news has been talking about the
story
constantly their top prime time opinion
people
have had no qualms whatsoever about
spreading the story as if it's true
despite it being less credible with
every single passing day so
great fox didn't publish it but they
reported on it
they just needed or wanted a degree of
separation
and the plausible deniability that comes
with saying as reported by the new york
post they didn't want to break the story
but since the new york post did they can
say something along the lines of well we
don't
this is what is being reported and as a
final reminder
news corporation owns both fox news and
the new york post now i'm not alleging
that for example one if one was more
conspiratorial
they might say they may have coordinated
fox news in the new york post both under
news corporation might have made the
decision listen this is better
if the new york post reports it and then
fox news can run with it rather than fox
news reporting it it'll be better
received
maybe that happened maybe it didn't
happen but the point is
fox news has been signal boosting it
they've had no hesitation whatsoever to
do it and when there's this much
vertical integration media consolidation
anything could be going on and in the
end news corporation
published it and news corporation
continues to signal boost it
on two of their different platforms
every single day it becomes less
credible
uh yesterday i brought you very
interesting clips from an interview that
dr anthony fauci gave to 60 minutes on
sunday night
now donald trump didn't like that
interview and has now called dr
fauci a disaster seems to group him in
with
idiots on coronavirus and openly mulled
the idea of firing dr fauci during a
call yesterday now remember that dr
fauci said
during his 60 minutes interview that
he's now getting threats
needs full-time security the direction
of the pandemic is unclear he's not
surprised trump got coronavirus
trump is furious this was all from a
campaign call that took place yesterday
monday
there were reporters on the call no one
is disputing what trump said here are
the reports
jeff mason from reuters tweeted that
trump is disparaging dr fauci on the
call
says people are tired of hearing from
fauci and
all these idiots and says that fauci has
quote been here for 500 years
trump also mused about firing
fouchy if it weren't for the negative
press he
would anticipate if he were to do it and
again said fauci is a disaster
will staken from abc tweeted about this
same call
that trump said quote people are tired
of covid people are saying whatever
trump is now discussing firing dr fauci
on a campaign
all staff call saying it's a bigger bomb
if you fire him caitlyn collins from cnn
tweeting quote on call with campaign
staff president trump says
people are tired of hearing about
coronavirus people are just saying
whatever just leave us alone they're
tired of it
people are tired of hearing fouchy and
all these idiots
fauci is a nice guy he's been here for
500 years
and then subsequently as reported by
caitlin collins trump said quote
fauci is a disaster if i listen to him
we'd have five hundred thousand deaths
which by the way we might eventually
before it's all said and done
before later saying it would be seven
hundred thousand or eight hundred
thousand
if there's a reporter on you can have it
just the way i said it
i couldn't care less caitlyn collins
adding that cnn was given access to this
call
by a source so every reporter who was uh
listening to the call
on the same page about what was said i
think that donald trump really is
thinking of firing dr fauci
he may be kind of floating it to see
what the response is from campaign staff
i think the response if trump fires
fouchy
i do think it would be the nail in the
coffin of trump's campaign i know we're
looking at key states and
comparing 2020 polling to 2016 and it
could go this way it could go that way
i think at this point if trump fires
fauci at this late stage
it's it's game over for uh for for
donald trump
fortunately well let me put a different
way
hopefully dr fauci will soon be working
for a different president his role in
fighting coronavirus
will be rehabilitated but i don't know
how much longer fauci is going to be
working for trump at this rate i think
if trump gets re-elected uh there's a
very good chance fauci
fauci gets fired and it's interesting
because when trump says people are tired
of the pandemic
we're tired of the administration
continuing to mess up the pandemic
that's what i'm tired of i'm tired that
there was never a coherent response that
there's this constant blundering of the
reaction to the virus
that's what i'm tired of and if trump
and his useless administration
would have listened to fauci from the
get-go the economic damage would have
been mitigated
and things would be far better than they
are now we would have fewer cases we
would have fewer deaths i am sick of
coronavirus trump is right
but i'm even more sick of donald trump
and his followers and their mishandling
i'm tired of staying home
so i don't contract or spread the virus
but i'm more tired of trump's cult
not doing what they should have done to
get this under control but for the
president to be tired of it too
won't help it go away and that's why he
has to be removed
now i mentioned there that jeff mason uh
reported on some of the things trump
said about dr fauci during that campaign
call
later in the day donald trump actually
called jeff mason a criminal
for asking him a question the
authoritarianism that we are seeing from
donald trump has not been funny for a
long time
but now it's taking on a more vicious
and disturbing tone donald trump
yesterday
on his way out to his various rallies i
believe there were
multiple rallies in arizona yesterday
called a reporter a criminal
for asking him a question this is how
bad it has gotten take a
[Music]
to be to look biden a criminal why is
that he is a criminal he's a criminal
he got caught read his laptop and you
know who's a criminal you're a criminal
for not reporting it
you are a criminal for not reporting it
let me tell you something
joe biden is a criminal and he's been a
criminal for a long time
and you're a criminal in the media for
not reporting it
good luck everybody have a good time so
donald trump said he would lock up
hillary clinton during the last campaign
he wants to expand libel laws to sue
media outlets more easily
he said barack obama and joe biden
committed the greatest political crime
in history
he has kicked reporters out of the press
briefing room he said a few days ago
that if he's re-elected he will lock up
the bidens and now
a reporter who asks i guess jeff mason
from reuters asked the wrong question
according to trump isn't asking the
question trump wants asked
he now is a criminal this is not funny
this is not a joke this is the greatest
attack on a free press
and on due process that i remember from
any president now if
if you have an example of a president
who has been more hostile
to the press and more authoritarian in
terms of saying that
his enemies should be locked up let me
know and i will i will examine that
um so then take a look at this fox news
goes back to discussion about what you
just saw
did they express dismay at donald trump
calling a fellow journalist a criminal
no did they express outrage at the
authoritarian insanity that has taken
hold
no fox news in reaction to that clip
criticized
reporters for as they say trolling trump
here is karl rove coming in to say the
problem is the press
um he also just said that joe biden is a
criminal and he has been for a long time
and that the reporters are a criminal
for not reporting that he did not seem
like he was in a great mood i have to
say
well you wonder why he keeps doing this
with the press because they know how to
get under his skin and they troll him
they don't talk about the issues that he
wants to talk about they talk about the
issues they want to talk about and uh
so maybe he's better off uh you know
giving them a message from
the podium and not making himself so
readily available it's amazing how
available he is particularly when
compared to his opponent
wow the president just attacked a
reporter
for asking a completely reasonable
question as a criminal
surely freedom loving first amendment
defending fox news is going to call it
out right
no the problem is the press and the
problem is that biden is in his basement
really dangerous what's going on here we
really can't afford
another four years of this and i will
say it is nice to see trump unraveling
so publicly
if it helps remove him and if it
horrifies voters into
either staying home instead of voting
for trump or going out and voting for
biden that's the one possible upside
but if all of this is endcapped
with bookended maybe is a better phrase
with
uh donald trump getting re-elected we
have a very ugly four years uh four four
years ahead of us
and um you know jail everyone is trump's
new thing
and he does seem to recognize at least
looking at his rhetoric in recent
rallies that biden may well
beat him starting to talk about you know
north carolina if you don't vote for me
i'll never come back
i might leave the country if joe biden
wins but
threats to jail your political opponents
this is something we
sure if you're a student of of history
and of 20th century
geopolitics you would know that this
happens
there are threats to jail political
opponents and sometimes it even happens
but uh for this to become so common and
to the point where
trump supporters cheer it in the united
states
it's very very ugly desperation may be
setting in
in some sense but if we don't get a
different outcome than we got in 2016
we're in real trouble here we're going
to have more on this on the show's
instagram page make sure you are
following davidpakmanshow on instagram
and follow me on instagram at
david.pakman for
video of me voting very powerful voting
video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
great to welcome back to the program
today don jeffries who's uh
incorporated a life of experience in
different areas
into many different books including
um survival of the richest which we
previously discussed and
most recently bulliocracy which is so
relevant
in so many ways right now it's great to
have you back on the program
oh thanks it's great to be back david so
let
i know that let's not dance around the
fact that this conversation is very
relevant
um uh to to donald trump but we don't
have to talk about trump at least not
not initially
what is your understanding of why
certain kids
end up uh becoming bullies
well i think that there is a and i i
cite in the book i i go there was a
study out of england that discovered
that basically the traits we see in
every bully are psychopathic type traits
many of them are
and unfortunately our society is ruled
largely by psychopaths and if you look
at the occupations where
psychopathic personalities are
predominant they're all the highest paid
professions
doctors lawyers ceos athletes
entertainers
clergymen uh policemen things like that
which policemen really aren't the most
successful but they have power
in terms of so uh this is when we look
at success
a successful person is indistinguishable
often from a bully
they trample on people on the way up uh
they they that's how they get their way
and as long as they win you're looking
in
the sports world certainly all the best
coaches virtually every one of the most
successful coaches have bullying
characteristics
and as long as they win that's fine if
they don't win well there's a problem
then they bring next coach on but i
think
our society pays lip service to uh
the fact that we like uh kindness or
whatever we don't i mean clearly it's a
kindness and uh empathy are looked at as
weak characteristics
where aggressiveness and being able to
confront somebody's power
especially in any kind of power these
are the qualities that we admire and
everything about our culture and
certainly the business world
uh says that now there there must be i'm
guessing
a um sort of circumstantial
aspect to this as well i mean in other
words
there must be something about the
circumstances
in which all those who might find
themselves predisposed to bullying would
find themselves in
some based on the actual reality they're
living
may become bullies and and some may not
right
sure well i and i think my the reason
why my book is different is the subtitle
says i believe it's a social hierarchy
that enables bullies i and that's why
i'm you know i
criticize the school systems especially
because this is where bullying is born
and i i don't believe they do anything
really to weed out the bullies because
they're not talking about how it's just
recent research
that has shown us in the past you know
we kind of had that stereotype well
the kid is a bully maybe he's uh his
father's beating him and he's lashing
bad at the world or
uh there's alcoholism there maybe it's a
single mother not watching him
living in a trailer park in poverty or
something that's not the case
overwhelmingly the bullies are the
popular crowd
and uh especially in the sports world
and we see the jocks bullying the
the nerdy types or whatever the goth
crowd and that's the dynamic you see in
every school system
and because of the uh the importance
that is placed on sports you know it's
ironic that these we send our kids to
school
and i you know it should be
theoretically that the kids who are most
successful
in school are those who get the best
grades because that's why you're going
there right
that's not the case very seldom are the
is the class valedictorian a popular kid
unless they also happen to be an athlete
which they could be
especially females a lot of the mean
girl types do very well
and have you know their national honor
society and things like that but it's
because they don't want to approach the
topic of popularity because
if you have a concept of popularity
everybody knows certain kids are popular
you have to have a contrasting unpopular
there's no such thing as beauty if you
don't have ugliness to contrast it with
so i think that is the problem that
those trench coat mafia types have to
exist
in order for the popular crowd to be
basically celebrities
in their school that i i document in the
book over and over again as you know
that
uh these school systems from the teacher
to the to the
principals the superintendent to the
local media to law enforcement most of
the time
they always poo poo the claims they
sweep them under the table your parents
will go
over and over again to the school
systems name the people who are bullying
their child
sometimes physically nothing is done
about it and a lot of times i've talked
i talked to too many parents whose kids
killed themselves they were bully sided
from it and even afterwards a lot of the
anti-bullying groups even will say no
it's more complex than that even when
they in their suicide notes
they'll say i did this because of
bullying or they'll sometimes even name
the actual bullies they still try to
sweep that under the rug and i think
that's the problem is they're not
addressing it correctly and instead they
have these kind of nonsensical
zero tolerance and no bully and those
schools as i point out
actually have more bullying in them than
the places that don't advertise that so
i think it's a complex issue but i don't
think anybody until my book
it was looking at the right uh at the
right culprit here which i think is a
social hierarchy which creates and
enables bullies
to talk a little bit about the social
hierarchy i remember back
when i was in elementary school middle
school in high school where
um the the popular kids and the bullies
uh were of varied economic backgrounds
in other words you had
they were like the rich kids and poor
kids and whatever you had really kind of
a mix
more recently i've talked to a lot of
different people who work in school
systems in different parts of the
country particularly in suburban
settings now this may be different in
urban settings or rural
but what a lot of them report is that
they see that
the not necessarily the bullies but the
popular kids tend to be the richest
kids how how does that pl is that a
broader phenomenon and how does that
play into the bullying
sure i think there's a lot of crossover
between this book and my book survival
and riches which you talked about before
because it's uh
certainly wealth has its perks
everywhere and uh if you're if you're
if you're a kid who comes from wealth
you're going to dress better
you're going to have the latest
accoutrements you're going to have you
know the latest uh
ipad or whatever what your latest cell
phone
those kinds of things you're going to
have access to things that are going to
make you seem better and kids are going
to want to hang around with you because
maybe you live in a nicer house maybe
you have a big swimming pool in your
backyard
so of course maybe uh you know maybe
your parents will
pay for their friends to go to some
concert or whatever i mean all these
things are possible there
whereas if a kid is is not wealthy they
might not have a cell phone or like they
have a crappy old cell phone or
something
and it's just it's like anything else
it's it's that's why looks are so
important i talk a lot about that there
is it
uh the way you can trump economics is to
be really good looking
you know a girl from the other side of
the tracks that just is
really gorgeous i don't think too many
people are going to be making fun of her
economic circumstances and uh
you know i i it's this is something i
think that again we don't we don't look
at but there i think there's a lot of
cross over there and i think that uh
not and i've i've been reminded many
times when i wrote this book it's not to
say that every popular kid i mean i
i was interviewed once by a girl said i
was a homecoming queen i said
i'm not saying everybody that is popular
is a bully but i think the vast majority
of of those bullies happen to be popular
and
and especially the cases that aren't
addressed by this
the teachers and the principals and
superintendents that are not addressed
logically
i think it's because of that popularity
i'll give you a perfect example that i
said in the book uh
there was a viral video a couple years
ago uh
that where the guy uh went to a
middle-aged man went to his uh
his local school school board meeting
and he wanted to talk about the bullying
that was going on in the local high
school he said you know i went there
you know 25 years ago or whatever it was
and he said
you know it was there then and he
pointed the finger at the school
superintendent
and he said you were the one who led the
bullying against me
you were the one who stuffed my head in
the urinal and things like and
it's shocking to see the stupid grin the
superintendent gets on his face
i mean instantly you could see he got
like a memory jolt
and he was exposed but uh he just got
well i'll tell you you know and he just
kind of laughed and
but you could see it coming back now who
knows how many other
school superintendents were bullies so
it it
it's certainly in that school district
or were any will any claims of bullying
be taken seriously if the guy in charge
was a vicious bully and i think we don't
know how
many people are like that and i have a
whole section in the book where i
uh i talk about all the uh the high
profile people
in our society is what from you know
actors to uh
you know actors the entertainment world
uh ceos just people that have
politicians
and it's astonishing how many of them
were the overwhelming majority were
popular in school
and so it's just if you look at it like
i think the group bowling for soup
had a song called high school never ends
and i think it
that's kind of the way it is where that
crowd not all of them and they're bill
gates people out there of course they're
outliers but
they're if you look at i mean people
don't know woody allen for instance the
quintessential nerd was actually a great
high school baseball
basketball player so you know if you can
get some rosie o'donnell was her
homecoming queen
so it's not a lot of times we'll look at
it and people don't realize and so i
think they're already
this the social hierarchy was very good
to them
and certainly the fortune 500 comes all
the overwhelming majority of these
people went to the high-profile
fraternities which i talk about in the
book that's where
out of high school you go to college and
it's the fraternities and sororities the
greek life
that's where you see the next step in
building those clicks
and of course that turns into business
business clicks because those people go
into high profile jobs and they're
fraternity brothers and again it
it it's this kind of corruption that we
i write about everywhere else we see
these kind of clicks form and
people that weren't in those
fraternities don't have a chance to get
in there
and so i think it's it's it's a very
complex issue but
the fact that it's not addressed at the
school level i think is the most
important thing and
all we're asking is that you know
somebody especially when you're bragging
about it and saying you have zero
tolerance if somebody comes to you it's
pretty clear-cut
if somebody comes to you and i describe
in the book there was a little girl that
came on from kindergarten one you know
kindergarten that looked like she'd been
15 rounds in the ring with mike tyson
and her mother naturally wanted an
explanation well the school said she
fell
yeah and the girl said no this little
girl's but this other girl's been
picking on me and she pushed me off the
slide so
you know if that's happening in
kindergarten and somebody's covering up
i i don't even know what that
explanation is but certainly
they need to look at the teachers
through the first line of defense here
there's the first person
the first people that could
theoretically stop it yeah and
and the principals who aren't backing
them up and then the superintendents and
i describe
many many cases over and over again that
you know the readers heads will swim
looking at them but
it's always the same story went over and
over and over again
they did nothing about it in worst case
scenarios
my child kills himself afterwards they
continue to demonize
they infer maybe it was us you know the
family you know there were you know that
maybe you were a fault
and they still don't claim any
responsibilities so it's it's a huge
issue
and uh in the limited time we have left
on when we look at
uh uh some of the behavior we've seen
from donald trump which includes
certainly bullying people on social
media and
and directing ire at specific
individuals
the irony of melania's anti-bullying
campaign while the behavior of her
husband is is completely antithetical to
that
we've since learned about some of some
elements of donald trump's upbringing
including that
his dad uh at minimum was verbally
abusive
um that you know there was this attitude
of never apologize for anything never
admit that you're wrong we
which we've seen donald trump take up
what do you make of all of that because
as you said it's not always as simple as
oh
the bully is a bully because they're
getting bullied at home
but what do you make of the trump story
well
that could have played into part there
and it could just be again he comes from
great wealth as my friend gerald celente
likes to say he was born in third base
and thinks he hit a home run
right there's so many and so many of
these guys do that so
he somebody like trump led a life of
privilege
his entire life he was born to the
silver spoon in his mouth
so there was it's hard to be humble
under those circumstances now in his
case he appears to have had a
very weird family dynamic his mother was
i think
probably just as strange as his father
if he's you know
and uh so i don't know i think somebody
said once that
uh nobody had ever told him that they
loved him in his life
and certainly if you look away kind of
trades in super model wise every 20
years
i don't think he's ever really looked
for love he's looking for a new model so
i think he's he's
kind of the quintessential superficial
guy
the ultimate materialist guy and his
personality unfortunately
is perfect for our uh burgeoning
idiocracy that we have now
i mean he's basically in many ways he's
like president camacho if you've seen
the movie
idiocracy i mean he's got the wwe
personality
and he has what has happened is he has
lowered the level of discourse and
everybody has joined him it's a huge
food fight so you have the other side
tries to bully him and they're always
down in the gutter
they're calling each other names and and
that's that's what it's turned into and
it's a
it's a shame but it's not surprising
because uh you know people
knowing of the trump's personality has
been out there for a long time
yeah listen to some interviews with
howard stern and stuff he's he's really
what was different is the populist
rhetoric
that a lot of us were attracted to
during his campaign i mean that was came
out of nowhere
yeah you know but no uh but the his
personality is but it's always been
packaged in that personality and
and i think because he is really
attacked constantly and if he had a
any kind of a sympathetic personality i
think a lot of people would feel sorry
for him
because he isn't but he just doesn't
have any of that and he laughs
and uh it's unfortunate that's you know
i wrote a whole
little section in bulliocracy uh about
the emergence of trump and uh it's
it's fitting and you're certainly like
you said his wife has an anti-bullying
message but we see that a lot of the
football players will
put people like russell wilson of the
seahawks who admits
what a big bully he was in school you
know he says yeah i used to rub kid's
nose in the dirt and stuff
and he runs an anti-bullying
organization now maybe he's reformed and
a lot of these football players
are in charge or sponsor these
organizations and my contention is that
football especially
breeds this bullying because it's you
know it's manliness and toughness and
you know if you're going against a uh
you know you're just natural if you're
coming up against the theater crowd
which you know may have gays in it or
whatever just very not macho guys or
whatever it's it's going to be natural
for those football players to come up
and bump against them and just you know
do what they do and it's it's it but
it's because the
schools place so much more emphasis on
sports
than they do in academics or anything
else and we see in society
the role that sports plays in our lives
and sports plays a tremendous
amount look at all the money that that
goes into it what the corporate welfare
that i talked about in survival
the richest the the most egregious
example of that
are all the stadiums that taxpayers
build
nfl stadiums especially in mlb stadiums
that are paid for completely
and it's because the those f that fan
base says no please don't move our team
right we'll pay for it and so i think
it's it's uh but again people don't they
don't want to equate
sports with bowling because i mean i'm a
huge sports fan i played sports i
coached sports i love sports but
i recognize how it breeds
this kind of behavior and especially
when it's not held into account
yeah and to be clear there are gay
football players as well uh
that not that you were suggesting that
that there were not of course
the latest book is bulliocracy we've
been speaking
with donald jeffries um don always great
speaking to you i appreciate your time
oh thanks so much for having me dave
it's a pleasure the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we have today one of those totally wacky
trump stories that came out yesterday
where it would be hilarious if trump
wasn't actually in charge of the nuclear
codes and it is now being widely
reported that donald trump got bored
earlier in his presidency
during a classified intelligence
briefing so he interrupted
the meeting to bring in a waiter to
order a milkshake
despite the waiter not being cleared to
be in the room or hear any of what was
being discussed trump just said bring
him over i want a milkshake
imagine being this desperate for a
milkshake
or this board during high level
classified briefings that you have to
you just must
get a milkshake right away the scene is
2017 at trump's new jersey golf club
there is uh trump's there having a
meeting with the cia
special activity center that's a unit
that is responsible for operations
including clandestine and covert
operations
where the u.s government doesn't want to
be overtly associated like this is
really really high-level stuff
very classified for lack of a better
term trump interrupts the meeting and
says does anybody want a malt
that's how he refers to milkshakes
insists the waiter
at his golf club be brought in we have
the best malts he said to the people
around him
the waiter comes in and of course it was
an immediate and early red flag
to the intelligence community to the
national security officials
that this presidency may not go so well
and of course it's gone very very poorly
since then
when trump said he'd hire the best
people i guess he wasn't talking about
national security staff or campaign
staff i guess he met the people that
will bring him a milkshake at a moment's
notice and this
this puts satire out of business how do
you make a parody of this
on saturday night live how do you create
an
uh a headline for the onion because the
the real headline is the onion headline
it's no different it's all the same at
this point in time
and i think that it should worry us
it's amusing but it should worry us that
when this story breaks
no one doubts that it's something trump
would do sure you know you'll have the
regular
defenders of trump say oh sources yeah
you can't
can we really trust it it's just too
obvious
that of course donald trump would do
something like this
and um think about it from the other
side by the way
imagine being an intelligence official
uh you're in the middle of briefing
trump about
some you know super high level covert
operation
and trump interrupts and asks you if you
want a malt
during a briefing and actually it is
anybody surprised that trump asked
anybody else if they wanted a milkshake
trump is so self-centered that that
piece
is actually notable although i'm sure
the you paid for that milkshake if any
of those national security officials
ended up
accepting one through your tax dollars
so i guess what we can say here is
yeah we have the opportunity to remove
him and very very soon a couple of weeks
can we be glad it wasn't obama who did
it
because if barack obama had ordered a
milkshake during such a meeting
it would have been a 24 7 national
security scandal
sean hannity would have been talking
about it rush limbaugh would have been
talking about it fortunately it was only
trump and by the way
the really important takeaway on uh
briefings is it has been weeks since
donald trump
received an intelligence briefing he's
held
must be like 12 rallies in the last two
weeks
he took a few days off but he had up to
two and even three rallies on some days
it's probably been a dozen rallies over
the last uh
two weeks and trump has not actually
received a
security briefing and intelligence
briefing for several weeks
that's the living nightmare which we
absolutely have to end
this is very very fun to watch over the
last few weeks former democratic
presidential candidate
pete boudageedge has been appearing on
fox news pretty often
and he's been laying out some smackdowns
that are truly a delight to watch it's
just a pleasure to watch it's a clinic
on how to deal with fox news so mayor
pete has been
doing appearances as a surrogate of and
adviser to joe biden and mayor pete has
this
it's almost like a natural ability to
casually deliver
hilarious and brutal attack lines that
you just have to see this first one
might be my favorite
mayor pete is interviewed by fox news
anchors martha mccallum and brett bayer
this was on the eve of the vice
presidential debate
the question was kamala harris and joe
biden
have or at least during the campaign had
different views on health care
and they wanted to put mayor pete in a
position to have to explain or defend
or kamala has this view joe biden as
this view how do you square it what's
the right view
and mayor pete brilliantly points out
that if you look at trump and pence
there's also a contrast from the primary
from you know
between their views which is that pence
is an evangelical christian
and trump is a president caught with a
porn star
and the looks on the faces of the fox
news anchors are just priceless
back to my original question about the
things that you know
when you run for president you have a
record on all of these
issues and then we've seen that record
and her stance on them changing
over time so there's no doubt she's
going to be asked about that tonight
can you give us some insight into what
she might say
to justify why she was for medicare for
all then
and is not for it now for example well
there's a classic parlor game of trying
to find a little bit of daylight between
running mates and if people want to play
that game we could look into why
an evangelical christian like mike pence
wants to be on a ticket with a president
caught with a porn star or
how he feels about the uh immigration
policy that he called
unconstitutional before he decided to
team up with donald trump
folks want to play that game we could do
it all night but i think what most
americans want to hear about is
are our families going to be better
protected than they have been
by this president who's failed to secure
america
in the face of one of the most dangerous
things ever to happen to our country
you actually get the feeling that this
is fun
for pete edge it's a game which i have
to tell you i love i've been on fox news
a couple of times and i also
see it as a joke and a game for myself i
don't see it as serious journalism
i see it more as what can i do to make
this interesting pete buddha judge much
better than me
at making it really interesting and
there's more of these uh here's one
where chris wallace
um tried to get pete but a judge again
on this primary stuff saying
do you stand by your criticisms of joe
biden when you were running against him
and mayor pete just handles it perfectly
well what i know is we definitely
need to turn the page even more now than
uh
when i was running for president a year
ago and what we need to turn the page
from
is a president who is incapable of hand
handling
a public health crisis that has now cost
almost a quarter of a million american
lives
thrown our economy into a total wreckage
and has clearly no plan to do anything
about it so yeah
let's turn the page and we have a very
clear choice between two
very different futures for this country
and any differences that we have
remember when everybody was was
hand-wringing saying how can the
democrats possibly unify
look how unified we are now you've got
democrats from across the spectrum
from the left to the center joining with
independents and republicans because we
can all see what's
at stake here i mean i i can't think of
an election
in modern history where the choice has
been this stark
and i know what side i'm on what's
brilliant about this
and perfectly done is that mayor pete
goes directly at the top issues for
voters
economy and covid and turns the question
completely around
and wraps it up with a bow and
especially if the audience
was a fox news you know typical fox news
audience
and they were hoping to see pete you
know up against the ropes
for pete to know that trump is failing
in approval on economy and coronavirus
and to turn it around and to go right at
those topics is absolutely perfect
here is mayor pete calling trump out for
not respecting his own followers
by stuffing them into rooms during a
pandemic look we've seen the vice
president
vice president biden campaigning across
the country there's one key difference
which is he's never going to stuff his
supporters
into a room without masks in an indoor
space
over the objections of local public
health officials when you do that
you show a level of fundamental
disrespect
for your own supporters so martha
mccallum started to push back and mayor
pete didn't back down let's take a look
the point is that there's respect for
the health and safety of the people
attending the event you set a certain
tone when you
lead people to a certain place and if
you lead people to danger you bear some
responsibility for that
in tulsa and more recently nevada he led
people into danger and you know how he
can tell
that you can tell what a dim view he has
of the intelligence of his own
supporters
was something they were made to do was
sign a waiver saying they wouldn't sue
them if they got sick and died
think about what that says for for the
respect that he has
very very well done and then lastly here
is mayor pete this is now the day after
the vp debate
he was interviewed by fox and friends uh
specifically steve ducey
and he is going right at donald trump's
comments about troops being suckers
and remember mayor pete is a veteran and
steve ducey tries to interrupt twice
mayor pete just doesn't allow it i also
appreciated that she stood up for
american troops you know the president
united states
uh uh calling those who served suckers
and losers uh saying he didn't
understand what's in it for them while
he was standing on the
the hallowed ground of section six but
mayor peter you know the president
knows what section 60 means sure indeed
the way he talked about the uh you know
folks like john mccain
i i hated to interrupt you but you know
the president has denied that particular
story
right but we know he's lying because you
know even in the middle of his time we
know he's like
i never called well because part of his
denial was he said i never called john
mccain a loser and anybody with twitter
can go and see where he did
so uh to believe that he was lying in
that part of his sentence but not
another part i remember this is a guy
who back when he was a wealthy young man
in new york
born to privilege thought to himself i'm
going to let some sucker go to vietnam
in my place and pretended to be disabled
i mean if you really believe the
president now on this kind of stuff
i got a bridge to sell you all right
really really good stuff i mean really
just a clinic
on how to deal with fox news and in each
of those clips you see something
different
but what's common to all of them is you
see the anchors faces steve ducey
martha mccallum they don't know how to
handle this because mayor pete is
brutally handling them and doing it so
quickly just
really really well done i hope we see
much much more of this particularly in
the lead up to and even after
this thursday night's presidential
debate for which i hope you will join me
uh i will be live starting half an hour
before the debate maybe even 45 minutes
on youtube twitch and facebook don't
miss it
also don't miss today's bonus show we
will talk about the jeffrey tubin
fiasco we will talk about slovakia
testing the entire country for
coronavirus and we will also talk about
the new zealand election results very
interesting uh
election results out of new zealand a
country that has handled the virus
very very well so get instant access to
the bonus show one of two ways
become a member at joinpacman.com
or become a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist dot com slash
david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video